hey Cory first of all to you let's just
talk about the scope of this 700 billion
dollars that's a big deal
compare and contrast it with other
companies out there so people get a
sense for how large this really is yeah
I mean so first of all I think market
caps not really the best number to use
if you're talking about the business you
really didn't use enterprise value
because with that you've got a hundred
and seventy eight billion dollars in
cash and equivalents that that Apple has
the next biggest company of course is
ExxonMobil I didn't look at we're closed
but I can and and ExxonMobil is is about
three hundred million I have a 300
billion dollars less in terms of market
cap in terms of enterprise value it's a
hundred and ninety billion less so
either way a much bigger company than
ExxonMobil the cash is a huge pile of
that but that growth valuation the
notion that this business can get a lot
bigger a lot faster is why it has that
valuation that's so much larger yeah
there you go I mean look at Google's
three hundred and sixty seven billion so
basically half the size of Apple we knew
Brian I know that you have loved this
company forever you've been a big
proponent of it a big believer in the
technology that's offered what are you
thinking right now you hear Carl Icahn
saying 215 what's your price target I
have one hundred and thirty dollar price
target on the stock and actually we're
getting close to it but I think it's
we're gonna see another quarter of a
very strong iPhone sales I think the
street is still very conservative about
the March quarter what we're gonna see
is a much better than seasonal period
for them it's still going to be a
sequential drop-off but a lot of guys in
the street are in the high forty million
dollar or high forty million unit range
for March we could see a unit number in
the low 60s for iPhone for March would
which would just be a staggering number
because that's where a lot of analysts
were in the December quarter so I think
that's what's going to help continue to
propel the stock
following that it's really gonna be
about to watch and how the watch is
received we believe that Apple is
currently projecting maybe 13 to 15
million units in production for this
calendar year
but the big question markets demand you
know one thing that nobody knows is
what's the killer application for this
platform and I don't think I don't think
we're gonna know until it launches and
maybe until we see if it's about 50
right I mean it and you know I've talked
with Karl about this and he's made the
point that you know look spending a
fortune on R&D
and this goes through cycles where every
three years or so you get some amazing
new product that really is is a game
changer we need though at some point to
get another new product do you think
it's gonna be the watch so the watch I
think is is a little less certain I
think there are other opportunities to
do something with television longer term
that could be meaningful there's been a
lot of talk and rumor recently about the
idea of them doing more in the auto side
we know right now they're just doing car
play I know it sounds funny to think
about Apple competing with Tesla
but who knew they would do a watch five
years ago the watch is the focus now and
that's where Apple is clearly focusing
the rest of 2015 in terms of R&D and
marketing and spend and it's gonna be
big but what we don't know is just how
big yet and that's where the big very
quarry that report was out there
yesterday that Apple was looking at the
potential for a an IKE our kind of thing
is this potentially quart you think it
not necessarily the hardware but just
we're talking about car connectivity
this software that's gonna go into
vehicles in the future so I was at Tim
Cook's speech yesterday at the goldman
sachs technology conference here in San
Francisco and cars were not discussed at
all I was on the breakout but I got when
I talked about the breakout that was
also discussed there as far as I know
what was talked about however was the
way that Apple took its time to
understand the Chinese market spent time
learning it and respecting it which is
what Tim Cook said and that led to this
product of the iPhone 6 and 6 plus which
could have been as much as 50 percent of
their sales into China in the last
quarter and led to those big numbers
that Brian was talking about and what
Tim Cook said in terms of what the next
product is and yes he talked about the
watch and I'll tell you what he had said
today about that if you care but he also
intriguingly talked about India and CIN
India's not a market where we've
invested the time to understand that
market but we do respect that market and
one could imagine
India India what he called a period of
time they would be just it's kind of in
some ways somewhat of a different
ballgame but there's a lot of hope that
with the new administration there that
the
they might be the real sign of the
future it's actually it's actually an
investment theme for us right now it
Rosenblatt securities because we are
seeing that smartphone market come alive
they only have 900 million mobile
subscribers and it's a very very small
penetration there this is going to be a
big opportunity for Apple Qualcomm a
number of other companies this year
really quick I know we're short on time
my producers want me to go but just
quickly Cori you know one of the things
he said was that we're not going to be
irresponsible with our cash we're not
gonna we're not going to hoard it but
they are doing a lot of buybacks and
they have made some acquisitions so
here's what they said if they do an
annual reassessment they are in the
midst of that process and he said we're
not going to hoard cash and that was a
big hint I thought that the current
buyback might not be the end because
they continue to generate so much cash
and they're doing that ancestor intends
they'll announce it and Apple with those
results and that could be yet another
boost for those are Washington's in
their current problems Karl gets his way
there will be plenty more buybacks thing